our solution is different concept also
there's like
a workout for the penis this is what i
say to my friend
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this is a
different episode and one that i enjoyed
very much meet daniel licinski the
founder and ceo of omed medical he is a
computer science engineer from the
technion technological institute at
israel and specialist in vlsi
technologies he has a few patents in the
field of anti-aging and neurology and
more specifically in the field of
erectile dysfunction the topic of our
conversation today
he was one of the first employees in
startup companies like typhoon
semiconductor melanox technologies today
nvidia
steinron founder of nd med medical
acting as vpr indian cto he is the
father of three boys two of them are
students at the techno institute and he
is married to aura a distinguished
lawyer at israel
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
very much for joining me today how are
you
very good thank you to you to
to get me here it's a pleasure for me
well we're going to talk about something
that's that's super interesting
something that maybe you know
30 40 years ago not many entrepreneurs
would would would go and try to solve
because of different
you know societal
considerations different perspectives
from the consumer market but
nevertheless a critical problem that i
think many are very thankful
uh to have your solution and we're
talking about erectile dysfunctions and
we're talking about
this problem that that probably still
has taboo in a lot of ways in today's
society and i'm and i want to uncover
that a little bit with you as well
but but before we even get to that
daniel tell me a little bit about your
own
background in in the medical and
technological sphere and the integration
between the two this isn't the first
company
that you're creating so who who are you
daniel
yeah okay so first of all i'm engineer
at electronics and my own computing from
the technion in israel
and my background is strong in
semiconductors so i was working for
companies like melanops and nvidia today
also fan semiconductors and so on
and till i work for a company which name
is
cineron which found by the doctor shimon
nekos and there i developed the first
home a hair removal on hair removal
that is it was commercialized so there i
need the market of the home use devices
for aesthetic medical devices it's near
to the medical and from there you know
something brings something else and then
i found in my previous company and they
made medical in israel today in the
stock market at israel
which is based on the radiofrequency
technology
and it was the first one they who
received a de novo fda approval for skin
tightening at home
based on energy based devices
and the principle of operation there
was
is the collagen remodeling or giving a
little amount of thermal energy to
start a collogen remodeling or renew
process in our body
so
once the fda approved my invention
the idea was to find another application
and then i find
the functional collagen fibers in our
male
penis in and and start to see that if we
are able to
improve such fibers we can improve our
directions
so
this
common pattern of
taking technology and medicine
and bringing it to consumers in the home
use
a lot of these things that you're
talking about aesthetics especially you
know these are things that traditionally
i'm thinking about them
as sort of a you know you go to a clinic
you need a doctor to do it
and not really something that you do at
home so what what is sort of this leap
that that you've been making here and
and why why focus so much on on the home
piece of things and the consumer part of
being able to independently do it with a
device at home
okay so basically i i focusing in both
the professional market and the home bus
market specifically in my previous
company for example i start for the key
opinion leaders core doctors and
cosmetic cosmetician and then the home
use so it's like a pyramid like this
uh in this company in augmented medical
i reverse the pyramid because
erectile dysfunction
um
nobody at meat has a problem
but everybody wants a little more
and you know at the beginning was
strange because i
tell to my
friends what are working on uh five
years ago
and everybody said
okay football i don't need it
but once i explained what are they
working on they asked me okay if you
need
some for one for clinical trial i'm
ready to be your your clinical trial
and these patterns
comes to every one i tell what they are
doing but nobody need
so
something
was clear to me that no easy
to to us to to demand to admit we are
less that we was when we was 20 years
old 20 24 years old
and to go to the doctor and open myself
say
saying doctor i am not the same i have a
problem this is impossible nobody is
going to do that
so
i decide to change the the change
the the
the chain of er administration of the
product standing by home use device in
this display i
last week i bought a bag from us from
the american ecological association
congress and
i saw what is going on with this product
this incredible reaction incredible and
everybody wants now in the clinics to
pass the professional machine so in case
the patients come to the clinic
so to do some professional treatment and
send him
on with the
let's say trainer device like we are
doing today
and in israel we are already under sales
we start last february or the last day
of january and the sales are increasing
almost 100 every month is something
really what is going
it's not a cheap device it's about 1 000
500 dollars
it's a lot of money also in israel
and
people are taking this device privately
from their smartphone come to the web of
the machine of the company or their own
learning
and worst case few of them call to us we
have a call center here and we send the
packets
privately to them to their hands
and then we brought
we broke the the barrier
of the
shame that
right nobody needs but everybody's
buying it it's a head it's incredible
okay and i surprised by myself i expect
good numbers but but know what is going
right now we are under manufacturing
pressure every day so it's very exciting
and very nice
incredible now did you know this before
so when you when you went out and and
and you know
designed the product
and worked with the team did you did you
know that this was going to be such a
hit that that even though the larger
market signals are telling us that no
people you know if you do a survey then
you know the 90 out of 100 people will
say no i don't need it
this would give an indication to most
entrepreneurs that okay maybe this is
not a product that we should be building
but you had a you had you were you had
an anti thesis to this right so why was
that so strong
okay so first of all i'm 50
53 years old so i can say that i am not
the same that i when i was 24 years old
okay so i see that something is
happening and some grad or some level of
deterioration so i start to learn what
is going on why what happened what we
have the drugs and the mechanism how it
is working
and i become
incredible surprised when i find that
all the mechanism to improve
erectile function today is just
improving the elasticity of the tissue
the
the tissue of the artery in the penis
but nobody take care of locking
the blood inside the penis
which is 95 collagen fibers and 5
elastin which both kind of
tissue it's reacting to thermal to
thermal
um a trigger so when i'm in reacting i
mean improving once you you hit or a
certain temperature so i can for i come
to this idea to a different level
different idea instead to work only on
the elasticity
to the income flow to dependence i also
take care especially take care of
locking
the
the blood in the penis so even your
elasticity is not the best you are
rocking it
better so it's become more functional
and this was a concept i taking a few
reads in the statistics and papers
understand that the 40 years old people
is about 39 percent of elective
dysfunction which
sounds a lot and the 70 is or is is near
to the 70 69
percent of the seven pc here so people
have erected this function
wow it's a huge number and of course the
severity of digital function is of
course increasing and bigger and bigger
and worse
with the age
and the drugs that today the markets
cities and dimitri and viegra
they did not
repair anything is a momentary pitch
for the problem which you need to timing
the pace with the with the issue but the
issue is becomes
worse worse and worse so
our technology what what i found is a
way to
improve the tissue tool to make you more
like i you was in in the previous way
when you was younger improving the
spontaneity the no need to take the
pills according with your starting point
if you people decrease the the level of
the drug and see people
avoid the draft for
live only with it with our device and
our device by the way is you do it your
free time not in front of your partner
so
so here's an important differentiation
you're saying one
one solution that the market has
proposed already is sort of this this
this patch right this
this momentary solution that will allow
you to function
during this set period of time but what
you're saying this isn't actually
dealing with
the more
long-term issue
and it's not actually able to help you
resolve it and and train you
to to fix it and so
that is the differentiation right of
what you were describing before
yeah by the way it appears at some point
of time doesn't work anymore because the
pill what they do looks like improve the
no the three toxin which is responsible
for the expand the elasticity of the of
the arteries
but
it was damaged at the beginning because
let's say plaque or any kind of other
tissues or other issues and these issues
continued happening to you it doesn't
disappear
so that the drugs take care of the
regulation the pd5 innovator which is
the enzyme to control the the nitrite
oxide so
maybe the piece works okay at the
beginning but the level of functionality
or efficacy of the pills goes and
decreasing because you are
you are a making world's worst situation
every day
so right so our solution is different
concept also like a
workout for the penis this is what i say
to my friend you try yourself at home
and you are you becomes more
healthy with the tissue that locked the
blood the the blood inside
so so what what is the product that
you're selling today and how does it
actually you know medically improve
so the product itself the the marketing
name is vertica and the vertica labs.com
is a website and
what it do it's it looks like a personal
device in order to
treat yourself this looks like i can
open it here somewhere it looks like
you put in between your words and you
treat
this is how it looks okay so it's very
easy simple you put your legs here so
you can open it your penis go inside and
then the device do everything for you
just uh four buttons on off plus minus
energy and energy button and from here
you don't need to do nothing the device
do everything for you it's a it's a
really smart device is taking care of
what is inside if i put my finger for
example here it will not apply energy he
know there is not a penis
so he's taking care about the
temperature he's taking care about the
the
electrical characteristic of the tissue
you know if you have a dive gel or
or not and it's coming the packets like
this okay everything
in the single box and
and oh it's just follow here
and it sounds like this
and it goes directly to your home in the
white box without any name any
notification and people can order it and
receiving soup to their private uh use
and
how does it actually work so what what
what is what is sort of the routine
that that a person would go through and
and how does this over time you mention
that it's more of like a workout routine
rather than a temporary fix wha what is
sort of this this workout that's taking
place here yeah it's very easy the first
month you need to do about up to three
times a week every time is 15 minutes
okay
and the second month we did twice a week
from there in the
in the in the trial for example we stop
it and we we start to measure results
but because now you have it's at home
you can continuously recommend to
maintenance once a week every every week
and it's enough but everybody do
according with its specific level we
have clients today that they continue
twice a week or three seven weeks
three times a week and we've applying
that they're stopping and they're back
to trade after few months when they
start to see the degradation again
so it's totally personal everybody
act a little different
what are we have clients
take care about 20 years old
really young people that i was sure it
will not work because maybe different
things so
it's for sure not exactly the jewelry
that i i i built but
we are
studying and we are learning right now
exactly the mechanism we are affecting
so for on the we have people in the 80
84 years old that they are using it so
quite exciting it's working
well and and what what is the actual
workout that's taking place so more
medically speaking what what what is
sort of this the the with this strain
thing that's taking place throughout
these routines that then let that then
allow people to
to have better erections so i do believe
we do two kind of results what we can
see
from our workout the you if we use 15
minutes let's say
each session we
the energy is focused on the what is
called tunica albugineer tonic
is the tissue that is go ah over all the
penis
in order to lock the uh the blood there
okay the blood comes through the
arteries and go out through the penis
from the from the penis
the penis are kinked by the tunica once
the tunica becomes um
no heart like no enough force to to lock
up so you have to lick
the blood from the penis as as much
less
blood is coming in and more blood is
leaking so if the same blood is coming
in is the same that is going out so
there is no erection in order to cause
the direction you need to
to have a high inflow and
less outflow over time the support is
happening
so
our work our routine what's do is
targeting the energy to the tunica
the tunica is responsible for the lock
the blood inside the penis and over time
it took about so when the a regulars
in influxes stay the regular state
this
the same amount of blood is coming in
the sign that is going out so everything
is deflected when you
are nerves stim
start the stimulation so you have more
flow in is and you lock the out right
over time the locking is leaking so this
starts to be like this and by the way
this is also going down the the inflow
so
we have traveled
a variables in the equation
that works together making the
dissipation very
bad for for us so but till now nobody
work on this one the the outflow and
this is the first time that this energy
is focused to this and mainly
try to
regenerate the tissue there which is a
95 percent collagen fibers and five
percent elastin fibers in order to lock
to get like a make more strain
the this this tissue and then we lock
the blood uh better
in addition we have more
a
a collaborative
collagen structure which is called the
tillax which gives the
like the word safe is a pillar that make
the
the form of the penis which is also like
a chain of collagen in through the
corporate cavernosa include the main two
areas of the penis and this is also
targeted by this device so we have a lot
of
structures of tissue we are targeting
and improving their
functionality and this is the theory of
sport we are trying we are moving into
the animal study to prove all this
theory what we have today is a theory
and we have the empirical result from
pinnacle pinkarosa
and we were surprised with something
else which i didn't expect
we are seeing immediately results when i
said immediately i say week maximum two
weeks that most of the patients of
client
they start go back to where they start
to receive again
more morning erections
this is for
all for all people they forget which is
boarding elevation and this is something
that comes for everybody and i want to
say something that
morning erection is something which is
not placebo
because the body
generates four erection overnight in
order to oxygenate oxygenate the tissue
of of the penis and in a when you become
older we are losing these capabilities
so you have less and less erection
overnight and the morning is the first
that we we we lose so when the patient
the client told me that he begged he to
receive morning erections
so we know we did our job but this is
happening very
soon one two weeks signed the start to
trade so for sure we know
there is something else in our process
that is triggering this
this this great result from our point of
view okay
yeah
of course people once start to see this
reaction
this feels comfortable they see
something is happening and and the the
mental security
aspect of the elected expansion becomes
more
they they win the confidence in they
have more confidence in their self and
becomes better
so incredible this is yeah
i really want to
you know want to mention that i think i
think this is just awesome and
it's something that you know both are
they're very optimistic on a on a note
do so you know a lot of this consumer
behavior that we're seeing a lot of
these taboo subjects that are getting
resolved by this these consumer products
that are allowing people to
independently
try out these medical techniques that
perhaps you know a few dozen years ago
were only available in the clinic and
would require some stigma to be
dissolved here you're actually
effectively
helping the stigma get dissolved through
your product and it sounds like beyond
that it's a fantastic product that then
it sounds like it that sounds like it's
doing some some phenomenal things for
people and um
on an entrepreneurial side it's very
interesting to think through these
consumer behaviors and to see your own
personal
journey and how things played out and i
really want to thank you for coming to
this show and for sharing with me
in these 20 short minutes it was really
enjoyable for me and and best of luck
with omed and uh and i can't wait to see
what happens
thank you very much i'm
really
proud to do what we are doing here
and we are growing every day you know i
just want to tell you one last thing
that we are almost three months in the
market okay also almost poor
and japan china
uk
[Music]
the
eu everybody is already signed with us
with agreement of distribution everybody
is excited and we didn't start i didn't
move to try this kind of
international sales so i very
excited with our future incredible thank
you very much thank you daniel
[Music]
you